♪
>> Tucker: ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ IS NOT A
GENIUS.
DOESN'T KNOW A LOT, BUT WHAT
SHE LACKS IN IMPRESSIVE
QUALITIES SHE MAKES UP FOR
WITH PURE AGGRESSION AND
MOXIE.
AND AS A RESULT SHE AND HER
FRIENDS NOW DOMINATE AND TO
SOME EXTENT CONTROL THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE THE ONES PUSHING
IMPEACHMENT.
>> CORRUPT PRESIDENT WHO
VIOLATES HIS OATH IN OFFICE
MUST AND WILL BE IMPEACHED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY TIME TO
START FORMAL IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> WHAT HE HAS ADMITTED TO
IS ALREADY IMPEACHABLE,
REGARDLESS OF FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS.
>> I KNOW IT'S TIME.
IT'S BEEN TIME.
WE MUST IMPEACH THIS LAWLESS
PRESIDENT.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN REGARD
TLAIB SHE IS A CHARMER, THE
LAST ONE YOU SAW THERE IS
SELLING IMPEACH THE MOTHER
FER T-SHIRTS ONLINE THAT WAS
MADE BEFORE THE UKRAINE
CONTROVERSY EVEN EXISTED.
NED RYUN IS THE FOUNDER OF
AMERICAN MAJORITY JOINS US
TONIGHT.
NED, FOR THE FIRST, I WOULD
SAY, COUPLE MONTHS THAT THE
SQUAD BECAME PROMINENT AND
REPUBLICAN TALKING POINT TO
SAY FOR OBVIOUS REASONS THAT
THEY ARE REALLY IN CHARGE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT'S STARTING TO SEEM KIND
OF TRUE.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK WITH EVERY PASSING
DAY NANCY PELOSI IS REALLY
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY.
THE INMATES HAVE TAKEN OVER
THE ASYLUM WHICH ISN'T
REALLY THAT SURPRISING,
TUCKER.
THE PAIR SAID DICK FAR LEFT
HAS BEEN EATING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR YEARS
AND NOW IT'S COMING TO THE
SURFACE.
YOU ARE RIGHT AMAZING BLEND
OF IGNORANCE AND PETULANCE
AND STUPIDITY AND HATRED.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
SELLING SHIRTS FOR 19.9.
KNOCK YOURSELF OUT SINCE
NANCY PELOSI ANNOUNCED
IMPEACHMENT TRUMP HAS
ERAISED 13 MILLION FOR
REELECT.
ADAM SCHIFF IS NOW A
PLATFORM FOR PAIR BUY.
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING TO
WATCH.
THE THING THAT'S CRAZY TO ME
IS DEMS ARE WILLING TO
DESTROY ALL OF THESE NORMS
BECAUSE ORANGE MAN BAD.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
TAKEN PLACE OVER THE LAST
TWO AND A HALF YEARS, RUSSIA
GATE, COLLUSION, UKRAINE
GATE, ALL OF THIS STUFF,
IT'S ABOUT ONE THING,
TUCKER.
IT'S ABOUT POLICY
DIFFERENCES.
THEY CANNOT STAND THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE NOT IN POWER
AND TRUMP HAS A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO GOVERNING NOT
ONLY DOMESTICALLY BUT ON
FOREIGN POLICY AS WELL.
SO NOW THEIR NEW APPROACH ON
ALL OF THIS SHALL IMPEACH
ALL THINGS.
IMPEACH KAVANAUGH AND TRUMP
BASED ON WHAT?
NOTHING.
POLICY DIFFERENCES.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE GOT TO
KIND OF WONDER, ONCE THESE
PEOPLE TAKE FULL CONTROL,
FORMAL CONTROL OF THE PARTY
AND THAT'S ONLY A CYCLE OR
TWO AWAY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Tucker: DO PEOPLE LIKE
ADAM SCHIFF REALLY BELIEVE
THEY ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO RUN COMMITTEES?
I MEAN, THERE IS NO PLACE
FOR ADAM SCHIFF.
>> THE AMAZING PART IF YOU
STUDY HISTORY THESE
REVOLUTIONS HAVE A WAY OF
EATING THEMSELVES.
LOOK AT THE FRENCH
REVOLUTION PIERRE.
I THINK THEY WILL START TO
REALIZE THEY WILL START
EATING EACH OTHER.
BUT AS DID YOU GO DOWN THIS
PATH, I THINK THEY -- IT
SHOWS HOW DERANGED THEY ARE.
LOOK AT THE IMPEACHMENT POLL
THIS WEEK IN THE MIDST OF
ALL OF THIS HYSTERIA ABOUT
UKRAINE GATE ONLY 36% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SUPPORTING
IMPEACHMENT OF TRUMP AND IF
YOU GET INTO THE HEARTLAND,
WHERE I GREW UP, TUCKER,
IMPEACHMENT DROPS TO THE LOW
20'S AND YOU START TO THINK
ABOUT HOW STUPID THEY ARE
WHEN YOU GET TO THE SWING
DISTRICTS OF OKLAHOMA 5 AND
ILLINOIS 14 WHICH ARE REAL
PICKUP OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
G.O.P. IN 2020, THEY ARE
GOING TO MAKE THOSE MEMBERS
WATCH WALK THE IMPEACHMENT
PLANK AND LOSE THE MAJORITY,
I REALLY DO THINK SO IN 2020
IF THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH.